let me ask
two rapid fire questions you're only
allowed to have one minute and it's
about predicting the future
okay
question one
vladimir putin
when will he no longer be in office
and will he step down or be overthrown
what's your prediction and a brief
explanation of that prediction now
nobody can predict the future but what's
your sense now some people are saying
the pressure is building he's going to
be overthrown or stepped down at the end
of this year
and some people say
surely he's going to
last outlast stalin's rule of 30 plus
years no evidence of a coup yet
none whatsoever
yet
he's pretty much at life expectancy for
a russian male
those are bad numbers
he's
69 gonna be 70.
so he's lived the life of a russian male
already
but he's got better doctors
than the majority of the russian males
in that
let's say
comparison set
so he could live a very long time with
good doctors
so there could be a coup at some point
but there's none today
in evidence
he could go because he's reached the
life expectancy or he could stay for a
long time
the thing to watch
about this
is
an organization that nobody pays
attention to
the fso the federal
which is the praetorian guard
the self-standing
bodyguard directorate
the only one the only organization in
russia that has any access to him
we've seen
no disloyalty no breaking of ranks
no defections
nothing in the public realm in open
sources about any divisions
or problems in the fso in the praetorian
guard
so if you can't
break that change that
uh
elicit defections there you can't
overturn him so authoritarian regimes
likes they're terrible they fail at
everything
they not they can't feed their people
they have trouble
achieving any goals
they only have to be good however one
thing
they only have to be good at the
complete suppression of political
alternatives
if you can suppress political
alternatives
you can fail at everything else but you
can survive as an authoritarian regime
so you watched navalny that's how that's
still alive
that's my the second rapid fire question
is what happens to navalny what are the
possible conclusions of what you said
quite possibly the second most
influential powerful figure in russia
uh is there is he going to die in in
jail will he become the next president
of russia
well what are the possible i wish i knew
lex i've been surprised that he's still
alive
i've been worried
that he will be killed in prison in a
staged fight
you know some yes
a security officer prison guard
puts on a prison outfit takes a lead
pipe goes into the cell they have a
quote fight
and navalny is killed i've been afraid
of that but he's still alive even though
he's serving a long sentence
so that leads me to guess
that people inside the putin regime and
maybe president putin himself understand
that navalny is their ticket to lift
sanctions
that navalny is
even more popular outside of russia than
he is inside of russia you know he's the
leader
in many ways of the up political
opposition in the country
even while still in prison his
organization's been destroyed
but it's he doesn't have majority
support in the population by any stretch
of the imagination but he's a big figure
in the west
including here in the u.s
and so navalny could be their ticket
they're kind of
get out of jail card meaning they
release him from prison
he gets appointed i don't know prime
minister even by the putin regime if he
were willing to accept such a position
and i have my doubts about that
and then that's how they lobby to remove
the sanctions against them
so he's a card that president putin
could play
and so maybe that's the reason he's
still alive or maybe there are other
reasons that we don't know
and so uh some alternative to putin is
more likely to arise
inside his gang
putin
as they say right inside his gang
where they tire
of his mistakes
they tire of his self-defeating actions
and they say patriotically for russia
we need to do something against move
against this guy
because
he's hurting our country and also
because i could do better
i'm ambitious as well as patriotic
but once again the problem there lex is
putin is surrounded
by this cocoon
known as the fso
he's he meets on zoom
predominantly with the rest of the
government including with the defense
and security
officials
they don't have
frequent access to his person and as you
were alluding
earlier to the pandemic they have to
quarantine for two weeks before every
meeting with him
and moreover you know lex
they don't know where he is
you see when they're on zoom with him
and
and the room
it's the valdai
his office in the valdai region looks
the same
as his office in sochi
or his office outside of moscow and nova
agariova they're made up to look very
similar on zoom
and sure some signs they're looking
where is it but
maybe they don't know
and so you're gonna move on him
and you're gonna jump him in his kremlin
out his dacha
outside outside moscow
and it turns out he's in sochi or vice
versa and it turns out the fso is loyal
to him and and won't let you anyway so
lex
we don't know but we watch this fso
really closely and we think that the the
elites if not putin but maybe putin to
understand navalny
as a really big potential political card
that they could play
you